sie werden es nicht glauben aber donald
trump hat gerade ein bisschen ärger
jetzt ermittelt auch noch die
steuerbehörde gegen den mann nur weil er
wohl in den 90ern seinen eltern geholfen
hat ein paar hundert millionen dollar zu
hinterziehen
haben wir doch alles schon gemacht jetzt
mal ehrlich neulich haben sie ihnen bei
seiner großen rede vor der un und sie
wahrscheinlich gesehen regelrecht
ausgelacht zwar eine totale demütigung
man möchte fast von einer pechsträhne
sprechen
heute ging ja diese bilder um die welt
die ihnen zeigen wir die gegenwart zu
airforce one hoch geht offensichtlich
mit klopapier am schuh am besten finde
ich offenbar sagt ihm dass keiner von
seinen leuten
weil die das lustig wenn er sich
blamiert ja langsam hat man sowieso den
leisen verdacht trump arbeitet längst an
einem eigenen comedy programm
vieles klingt jedenfalls so
respekt ja wirklich donald trumps gehirn
ist so groß dass sie oft zu umständlich
ist es mitzunehmen aber seien aktuell
größtes problem wissen sie ist natürlich
die affäre kevin o brett kevin dieser
ernst konservative juristin trump auf
biegen und brechen an den obersten
gerichtshof bringen will morgen könnte
es passieren
und das obwohl drei frauen kevin o
sexuelle belästigung vorwerfen
ja die psychologieprofessorin blazy ford
zum beispiel sagt kevin o habe 1982
versucht sie zu vergewaltigen
sämtliche experten fanden ihre aussagen
im senatsausschuss letzte woche
berührend und glaubwürdig was tram nicht
davon abhält sie regelrecht nachzuäffen
hanno
[Applaus]
women for trump nehmen die medikamente
oder was warum der präsident der
vereinigten staaten ist eine frau nach
die so mutig war öffentlich über so ein
traumatisches erlebnis zu sprechen ist
unfassbar
wir schauen mal live zu unserem heutigen
washington korrespondenten ulrich von
heesen ulrich kennt trump überhaupt noch
irgend eine schamgrenze nein
das ist ja der vorteil wenn man trump
ist keiner erwartet mir irgendeine
menschliche regung der präsident ist die
stimme aller geilen weißen männer donald
trump diese fleischgewordene
erektionsstörung dreht den spieß einfach
um wissen sie wer das eigentliche opfer
ist die ganze sache wenn man dringend
schützen müsste das ist eine sehr
beängstigende situation wurde schuldig
willst bist du deine unschuld bewiesen
hast ich denke es ist eine sehr
beängstigende zeit für junge management
totale verunsicherung welche was darf
man das fragen sich jetzt viele junge
männer wie ich hier hier findet ein
kulturkampf statt der mann die krone der
schöpfung gottes premium produkt steht
plötzlich am pranger
muss sich rechtfertigen das kind nicht
ja aber warum wird stammt diesen keller
denn unbedingt durch boxen weil er weiß
dass er die stimmen der halbwegs
vernünftigen frauen verloren hat ihm
geht es nur noch um echte kerle typen
die pickups waren sich am sack kratzen
und bier trinken
denn das wurde in der senatsanhörung
zwischen den zeilen schon klar
der kevin glaube ich woher soll das
wissen war ja immer besuchen
also man ist ja auch völlig egal wie
viel bier einer mit 16 getrunken hat mir
fehlen den späten 80ern auch zwei drei
jahre entscheidend ulrich entscheidend
ist die frage ob er drei frauen sexuell
belästigt hat ist doch völlig wo er will
den demokraten eine lehre erteilen und
den aufmüpfigen frauen
trumps eigenes frauenbild ist ja diese
woche sehr schön deutlich geworden bei
einer pressekonferenz hier im garten als
eine reporterin was fragen wollte hätte
das ist so unglaublich oder du denkst
nina sagt der mann von dem das berühmte
zitat stammt belgien ist eine
wunderschöne stadt im jahr 2018 stellt
er sich hin dieser orangene pavian und
vermittelt ein frauenbild aus dem frühen
mittelalter der kann sich doch nicht
ernsthaft
wir müssen leise seien hier die kollegen
von rtl macht sich für ihre schalte
fertig wie eine richtige reporter sag
mal schnuckelchen was machst du später
noch wachsen bier
ich mag mir ein bier trinken
mach einfach weiter ulrich von heesen
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]